yeah I think Evolution just in itself is
an emerging property that we're
describing so yeah it's just multiple
different interactions that we're trying
to explain
and we can never
really we can only ever grasp it at a
higher level and that's it it it's a
kind of search process which accumulates
information yeah and unlike almost every
other search process that we've created
in computers it never converges it's
just still emerging just continuously
accumulating information it's an
agent isn't
it well simply that they've become more
and more complex with time right
and intelligence has existed from the
GetGo um as soon as like as soon as a
single agent exists intelligence exists
and so the evolution of it is simply a
byproduct of multiple agents then
existing and multiple different types of
Agents existing
um yeah I I don't want to say that you
are an agency chauvinist but you were
just saying that there might be one
particular way of demonstrating agency
and earlier on you were saying okay well
we should look at the overall system and
there is a distribution of agency it's
it's it has lokai all over the system
and you could draw a big boundary and
say well that thing's has agency but you
could be much more efficient and you
could draw a smaller bound
and that smaller boundary would have
almost all of the agency of the big
boundary because most of the things in
the big boundary are just mimicking or
stealing agency from things in the small
boundary so Keith you were saying it's
really important for us to encapsulate
the most agency possible which is to say
the most amount of temporal planning in
the smallest
space yeah and so what I had in mind
there Carl was just that imagine imagine
I'm I'm a pilot steering a ship okay and
if somebody looking from the outside
looked at the ship they may decide that
the ship as a whole is an agent you know
it's planning like obviously it's
planning it navigated through you know
the Suz canal and some locks and
whatever else but but there's a smaller
subsystem if we had the ability to
analyze this we could find a smaller
subsystem which is the pilot you know
this human being who's sitting at the
controls who's actually the the agent
right and maybe you could shrink it down
a bit further and say it's really just
all his his brain it's everything inside
of his skull that's kind of doing the
planning but then we realize that agency
actually has the two sides of the coin
like it has the planning side of the
coin which is only happening up in here
but the enaction side is perhaps
different because if you're looking at
the all the Machinery necessary to enact
the plan it's the Pilot's brain and the
Pilot's body and the ship itself and all
its components so I think you you know
you can come up with a different
boundary if you look at the inactive
piece of agency versus the planning
piece of a agency but I think you do
need to on the planning side you need to
at least shrink it down to that minimal
system that contains the the actual
planning that's why I paus when you ask
your last question cuz I knew what you
were asking about but I also knew that
no one else knew because you'd had a
private conversation with Keith before
so thank you for unpacking that the free
energy principle is a mathematical
principle which allows us to describe
the time evolution of coupled random
dynamical systems the perspective opened
by the free energy principle starts from
the question of what it means to be an
observable thing in our physical
Universe at least according to Dr
Maxwell ramstead who recently published
the free energy principle ay now I
really recommend you read it guys it's
only about a 5 minute read and it will
clear up a hell of a lot of confusion
about the free energy principle now I
highlighted a few things when I read the
paper from Maxwell last night which I'm
pretty much going to read out verbatim
here now um he said that the free energy
principle allows us to partition a
system of Interest into particles or
things which are to be distinguished
from other things in the system the free
energy principle rests on this idea of
sparse coupling which is that things can
be defined in terms of the absence of
the influence between subsets in the
system or between other things right the
subsets in the system are the things if
they exist exhibit certain properties
now Markoff blankets formalize a
specific type of spareness or separation
between things in the system which helps
us identify the things from the non-
things now Maxwell notes that this
self-similar pattern repeats itself at
every single scale that can be observed
from rocks to rock stars and Beyond he
said that the free energy principle
tells us something deep about what it
means for things to be coupled to each
other other but distinct from one
another at the same time it implies that
anything which exists physically in the
sense that it can be reliably
reidentified over time as the same thing
will necessarily look as if it tracks
the things to which it's coupled he said
that this tracking behavior is
formalized as a kind of abductive
inference which in this case is
variational Baye or approximate basian
inference but I should be clear that
this is not a double implication
abductive inference can be implemented
in other ways and we don't know how it
happens in humans Dynamics are simply
formal descriptions of behavior and
mechanics are mathematical theories that
are developed to explain the functional
form or the shape of said Dynamics which
is to say they explain why the Dynamics
are the way we observe them to be now
the free energy principle is based on
the idea that spareness is key to
thingness the main idea is that
thingness is defined in terms of what is
not connected to what think of a box
containing a yellow gas as opposed to a
box containing a rock we have strongly
mixing Dynamics so any molecule in the
gas could find itself arbitrarily
connected to any other such that no
persistent thing can be identified in
the Box by contrast a rock does not mix
or dissipate into its environment in
other words The Rock exists as a rock
because it's disconnected from the rest
of the system in a specific way now
Maxwell concluded that the free energy
principle stands in contrast to
approaches that would split the sphere
of the mind or life from the sphere of
physical phenomena such as versions of
the inactive approach which he's not a
fan of now finally he also argued that
this philosophical perspective is not
physicalist reductionism which is to say
a reduction of causal efficacy to Mere
physics but rather in his view a deep
commitment to anti-reductionism
emphasizing the cause or contributions
of things at every scale to the overall
dynamics of the nested system now I must
admit I don't understand that part I
mean as far as I understand the free
energy principle is materialistically
reductionistic and um you know friston
said as much when I asked him so I think
the emphasis here from Maxwell is the
multiscale Dynamics and the fre energy
principle at its core is all about
things and at some point Things become
agents and we seem to be agents and a
lot of it is because of the latent
Dynamics and the locus of complexity in
those Dynamics agency isn't necessarily
encapsulated within the locus of a
particular thing it's distributed
throughout the Dynamics of many things
in the system but it seems to be the
latent complexity but also the lack of
convergence and stability and what I
mean by that is if you look at a a
meteor or if you look at a storm on
Jupiter it's kind of converged so
there's some kind of stability it's near
the boundary of chaos but it's
stabilized whereas we humans for example
we have this embedded complexity of the
Dynamics in in the system around us but
we still have that planning which is a
function of being embedded in that
Dynamics and I guess it's just so
difficult to artic calate exactly what
that bright line is between just a
dynamics of a thing and a thing with
agency yes I have a very simple view of
this which which um situates um
Quantum statistical and classical or
conservative uh mechanics simply in
relation to scale so at the uh at the
very small level um everything is
stochastic chaos it can only have a
description in terms of um probability
distributions where things are just
happening so quickly uh your in a
Hinesburg sense you you you you can't
sort of tie down what's actually going
on and as you move to very very big
things massive bodies you get asteroids
you know the the motion of the Heavenly
planets that have a lrin mechanics that
have a classical classical mechanics um
in between I think you have things like
us
you we're not Quantum but nor are we
just massive bodies and what does that
mean well it's a beautiful mixture of
conservative and dissipative Dynamics in
the sense of things like the helun
decomposition that the and that um that
mixture I think gives you exactly the
kind of stochastic chaos you need to
have this you know to have the
complexity and the um reader say for
example long range correlations over
time for example a deep memory of what's
going on um but also that itinerancy
that you get with with with sort of um
agency and biotic self organization
because you know we've spoken about
systems having goals as if goals but
it's actually kind of diffused in the
Dynamics of the system and I think it
might be a similar thing with agency
that we we think of the agents as having
this effective depth of counterfactual
planning so they're planning many many
steps into the future many different
trajectories but I'm really interested
in the diffusion of that cone of half um
you call it an itinerancy but that cone
of traversal it it must be somehow
embedded and diffused in the system and
somehow when an equilibrium is formed
there's a kind of information sharing so
it's as if the components of the
Dynamics are planning but it's a kind of
resonance between the components in that
system I'm very bad at articulating that
but do you see what I'm saying it's if
rather than a single agent imagining all
of the possible paths there's some kind
of resonance between all of the
components in the system yes well I I
don't think you were bad at articulating
that um but if if you want to articulate
it in a way that somebody um dealing
with either um deterministic or chaotic
um uh stochastic chaotic systems and I
think what you're describing is exactly
the the generalized synchronization of
chaos that characteriz is biotic
self-organization that will entail the
kind of agency or will be necessary to
manifest or evince the kind of agency
we're talking about which is this future
pointing uh aspect of
movement U so you you you're what you're
describing would I think be read as um
somebody in the maths of you random
dynamical systems perhaps um as
generalized synchron synchronization or
synchronization of Chaos if you're a
statistician that's just saying that in
virtue of there being a synchronization
manifold between you know agent a and
Agent B or me and the rest of the world
um my Eon Niche uh then there is um the
the other just because there is this
synchronization manifold in our joint
space then there has to be a high Mutual
information and just if you were three
free energy um principle theorist you
would say yes of course because the
expected free energy just is a
constraint Mutual information so if you
write down the the expression for the uh
the free energy functional the expected
free energy functional underwrites the
paths that we take it is just um the
mutual information plus constraints and
those constraints are the are the the
goals they're just description the
characteristic states that shape that
synchronization manifold so all of those
things the resonance that you mentioned
the distributed aspect ECT um are all um
I I think foundational and
quintessential reflections of something
that that um has got um a pullback
attractor if you if you talking to Chris
fields or you you you're doing this from
the point of view of quantum information
Theory what you've just said is just the
principle of unitarity that ultimately
when you Converge on your attracting set
everything is coupled and when
everything is
synchronized everything now becomes um
if you like is effectively conditionally
dependent that there is this Mutual
information and of course that's one way
of just saying that or one way of
looking at the license for people like
me to say what's happening on the inside
somehow represents what's going on on
the outside it's just another way of
interpreting or placing a teeology on
that kind kind of yeah so so could we
could we look at a a dynamical system
and and point to a locus of
agency well I guess so I want to say two
things because this came up with Wolfram
too which is um I don't I don't agree
with the the conflation of agency with
non-determinism like in my in my
worldview in fact I don't even
necessarily agree Carl that at the
deepest deepest level of the Universe I
don't think you have to have actually
stochastic or true random processes I
think you can just have like such highly
non linear chaotic systems that even
though they're totally deterministic you
know they're they're for all intents and
purposes not predictable you know
whatsoever and so therefore you can just
model them as you know stochastic um and
so I think you could have a universe
that was super deterministic just
deterministic at every conceivable level
and yet I would still identify agents I
would say that I'm an agent even if I'm
even if I'm completely deterministic
right um so I guess that's the the first
thing I think of and the second thing is
sure you may be able to have multiple
ways Tim of of identifying a Locus um
but it doesn't necessarily mean that all
ways are are extant in any particular
organism so even though in my brain it
may have been possible that I could
identify my agency with you know a whole
variety of combinations of of neurons in
the kind of Puttin them sense like it's
it's only one of them that actually is
manifestation of that and I think uh the
reason why that's the case is the same
reason why putnam's Rock like falls
apart it's like yeah you may be able to
map a conscious process to a particular
history of the rock but the very next
time step The Rock will deviate from
that it's not going to continue along
the same trajectory that the conscious
brain would have language has this
memetic quality we all speak different
languages you speak certainly
significantly more advanced form of
language than I do um car but
um so language is a bit like an organism
um it's alive it's parasitic on humans
there's an asymmetry in velocity uh
weirdly our culture and language evolves
very quickly our DNA evolves very slowly
and if you killed all humans the
language would die um kill a few humans
the language lives on and not only that
I from a cognitive science point of view
I believe that um even things like
syllogisms you can argue which things
are platonic which things are cultural
but the way that we think all of those
tools and programs are embedded in our
culture which is largely our language so
then it erases the question well if we
have this agency experience
Consciousness planning call it what you
want reasoning which emerges from all
these little things in our brain and
even our sense world could it be argued
that language
itself has a form of agency so when I
say Carl it's my uh it's my goal to do
XY Z I want to get another PhD and maybe
the super organism has entirely
different designs on what it wants to do
and I'm deluding myself that I have any
free will at all I mean do you think in
principle language could be you know
language as a super organism could be
self-aware no no why not so if you're
saying that the super organism is just
drawing a Markoff blanket around a
particular culture or um you know
Society or population or ensemble
and not set ofon specifics I think you
you you made a very clear point before
that you know you cannot get a joint
free energy Minima um just by looking at
one kind of species you know it has to
be an ecosystem that necessarily has all
sorts even at one given scale all sorts
of different kinds of um phenotypes
within it things to eat things that do
the eating things that do the know the
um the breathing and the things that you
breathe that scale-free perspective
uh and particularly the separation of um
temporal scales and scales that
distinguish between an individual and
the population on the ensemble in which
that individual finds herself um is
absolutely fundamental and that
certainly could be attributed um um sort
of mental states of a of a minimal or uh
basic sentience sort but I don't think
that they plan we're transgressing from
the material world into the information
world that's not necessarily a problem
because the the free energy principle
does that anyway I think the more
interesting distinction is that we we
are transgressing from an agentive world
to a non-agentive world so if we think
of language as being the and it's very
similar to dorkin's selfish Gene yeah
yeah you had this beautiful idea that
that um you know genes in a sense they
they live in this almost in a different
substrate yeah they don't care about
what you do and could could language be
the same what yes oh yeah but then could
you in any way conceptualize this super
language structure as having agency or
agents no no no why not um because I am
um when you say agent I hear something
that plans so if you're say does natural
selection plan no does a weather plan no
is there a kind of basic sentience and
information gathering in the weather and
natural selection absolutely there's
masses of self- evidencing and autop
poesis at various scales so it's when
you say agent I read that as um very
particular uh kind of system Beyond just
having active States it has to be able
to to plan so language can be used for
planning and it can certainly um um and
indeed you know literally in the it's
actually under reviewing uh uh
neuroscience and bi behavioral reviews
as we speak it is simple to show that
language is an emergent property when
you put lots of free energy minimizing
things together so you can the free the
minimum The Joint free um joint free
energy minimum is just that in which a
common ground in the common language
emerges it's trivial it say maximize
Mutual predictability maximizing Mutual
predictability minimizes joint surprise
joint surprise is basically one way of
reading um free energy uh and it's a
negative of of of the self-evidence that
we're talking about before so language
is an emergent property and certainly um
is um as such will look as if it is u a
facilitator of you know self- evidencing
and intelligent processing um but in and
of itself it does not plan but this is
one of those as if questions again um I
mean for example we had the um all of
the horrible violence going on at the
moment but there lots of memes
circulating on Twitter and the memes
adapt and if you look at the memes as
being a kind of agent in in in a way you
could you could almost see you could
view them as you know as if they were
planning or had a I see well okay well
perhaps I'm being too um too specific in
my interpretation of agent I mean if you
interpret agent as something that has
active states that um that you know you
could draw a boundary around it from my
perspective a Markoff blanket or or if
you don't like that then you input and
output ports so if something has an
output port or has um active States um
in in terms of a sort of a particular
partition under a markof blanket if that
is an agent I think yes you you could
certainly say that anything that you can
draw a line around you can IDE you can
individuate from something else
including language any meme um you know
I don't want to s generaliz um the
selfish Gene too much but anything that
survives and endures then inherits all
the properties of um all the as if
properties afforded by the free energy
principle um and if it has active States
then it has that kind of agency so
perhaps we we can we can
um we can reconcile any um any you
really want to say language is is you
know has has a kind of um basic engin if
you want to say that U then I would have
to say yes if agents are just defined by
um influencing States beyond the you
know beyond the thing that they they
are I repeat for me though agency um
implies not just that you act upon the
world like a thermostat or like the
weather or by like natural selection it
actually means that you um you have
you're implicitly a generative model of
the future um and you just come back to
your mimicry argument there is a way of
telling the difference so as a you'll
never know but there is a way of telling
the difference between a mimic and a
planner yeah and that's the fact that
the mimic will have a state action
policy which means that yes there is
something that is learnable but all that
can be learned is a mapping from being
in a particular state to being
particular action so this of course is a
holy grail of Q learning and you know
all all the Deep learning that we've
seen um nowadays um under the hood in
terms of indeed large language models
um that is not the same as planning
because once you have planning in play
then you can work out what I will
believe well what if I do that and of
course what I will believe if I do that
depends upon what I believe now
it's not a function of the state it's a
function of the of my beliefs about the
state so there are no State action
policies so given the same state a
planning agent will do a different thing
the next time around and mimic will not
so although I said you'll never know the
difference between the two there are
ways of uh sisting the right kind of
data to distinguish between a mimic and
a large language model yes and um a true
agent that PL
uh that has that sort of perspective
aspect to it simply because it will
remember and learn or um um inherit from
it from its previous being being in that
in that kind of state yes yes I wanted
to tease that apart because it's very
similar to um charm is in a sense
talking about Consciousness being a
strongly emergent property so you know
he was um a material non-reductionist
and in a sense this is a very similar
material non-reductionist argument which
is that language itself is is strongly
emerging and it and it does lead to this
wonderful thought experiment that you
can have virtual agents so agents that
are a thing they're a you know a
homogeneous thing but they link to a pan
playay of underlying physical material
agents and then you could have a
hierarchy of virtual agents and also
there's this concept very similar to in
data bases it's called eventual
consistency which is that you know you
you write something but you might not be
able to read it back immediately you
might have to wait a while it's a
similar thing with the agents the
virtual agents they might not be able to
directly act they as if act and they
only know that they've acted at some
point in the future because actually
they're parasitic on this piplay of
physical agents in the material world
but yeah it's just I suppose it's just
playing with this material chauvinism in
a way isn't it which is that to to um
how strongly do you hold on to the
materialism
yeah well that that that those two
examples you
gave I thought that that was quite
fascinating because um one structural
feat feature materialistic feature that
distinguishes between um particles that
have generative models of the
consequence that can
plan is that the the um random variables
the latent States covered by their
generative Model includes their own
actions so this is a bit subtle it it's
the there be there are certain kinds of
things that have active States like
thermostats and um they have attracting
sets and they do good homeostasis and
possibly even do quite sort of
protracted kinds of itinerant
homeostasis that look very much like
mimics or allostasis but you know at no
point does the generative model um H
cover or in for their own actions they
know what they're doing because you know
their actuator the the the the heating
element um um direct directly um is
sensed by the internal States but for
other kinds of systems things things
like you and me um we don't really know
what our muscles are doing all we can do
is sense the consequences through Pro
perception of what's going on which
means that our actual actions are um
latent States so suddenly now from the
point of view of the generative model on
the inside if it exists um then my own
actions become the cause of my
Sensations and that sounds very very
similar and of course I have to act in
order to produce the sensations to make
the inflence I'm doing this so you get
this sort of exactly as you describing I
have to wait the virtual machine has to
wait until the physical machine tells me
what what what I did so there's a
temporality which is inherent in that
kind of structure so which sounds a
little bit like was it
enduring what was
the databases oh um consistency
consistency yeah yeah but but I suppose
you're you're describing a kind of
message passing process essentially and
no reason I don't think in principle why
the message couldn't Traverse the
material non-material um boundary and
then come back again and and and in
principle be diffused to many many
underlying agents yes um absolutely
beautiful by the way I've got covid
which is why my voice is completely
ruined I did think about whether I
should even bother recording this and
I've decided to persevere regardless as
I can within
my my limitations so hello GOI
Tech hello everyone it's Tim here from
mlst your go-to channel and podcast for
all things machine learning Ai and
philosophy creating content for mlst
takes a considerable amount of time and
resources please consider supporting us
on patreon every bit helps although
please only donate what is an
insignificant amount of money depending
on your situation anyway thank you so
much for your time and I can't wait to
welcome you to our patreon family
signing off for now cheers exponentially
more likely Ry it's an honor to meet you
it is an honor to meet you Tim introduce
yourself um I'm ridy Ry Jane piter
that's my full name and I'm a PhD
student at the moment at the University
of Oxford um and I'm also being funded
fully funded by versus and so I spend a
lot of my time working on very exciting
projects here as well so what are your
research
interests mainly um computationally
analyzing psychological phenomena and uh
psychopath pathology as well um so it's
trying to just understand human behavior
human
interactions at a singular level at a
multi-agent level um in a more
computational way just to understand the
cognitive processes that are being
engaged and kind of ground this
empirically by collecting behavioral
data and see whether the computations
are explaining indeed what we see is
happening decomposing cognition into
autonomous agents what what does that
give
us I think um that gives us a very
intricate realization of the processes
that are actually happening um which is
we are a perception or We are perceiving
the world as a function of how we sample
the world which is how we're acting
within the world right um and so at
least in my PhD work what we are finding
is that people's perception of the
degree of agency they believe they have
so the degree of control they believe
they have in their environment is simply
a function of of how much they're
engaging with the environment because
the more that you
engage the more relevant data you
receive
we we are not only engaging
in perceiving the reality of the world
and then acting to only
optimize the utility function so to get
as much reward as possible or exploring
so in gaining as much information as
possible it's actually a function of
both and they are very simply put
together so then there's a tradeoff
between the two a balance between the
two and so I think that's where the
autonomous Agents come in it's
explaining that we're not really just
inanimate object perceiving the reality
as we as we see it but rather we move
around and it's only because of that
that we see what we see interesting so
so yeah as as you say like the free
energy principle it formulates in a very
principled way like this trade-off
between exploration and exploitation you
know energy and entropy
and but I I think there's more to it
than to say exploration is what gives
rise to agency and one thing I wanted to
explore which I think is very
interesting is this notion that an agent
um it it could be at the top of the
stack so it could be composed of a a
hierarchy of Agents below it yeah and
when we're talking about an ecosystem of
Agents your actions become a kind of
weird composite of other agents in the
system yeah which could arguably
truncate your
agency uh well that's only when you use
the definition of agency is Free Will
right I I would argue against that I'd
say that it's
almost because it's
explainable it is somewhat deterministic
mhm um in a probabilistic manner of
course all of this is grounded within
probability
Theory I mean maybe we could explore the
Free Will thing just a tiny bit because
I guess like one thing that that
interests me is just like there's in my
opinion no such thing as a pure
intelligence uh in in some sense there's
no such thing as we can do whatever we
want yeah right so we are situated in a
physical environment yeah we can we can
do certain things so straight away that
truncates our free will because we're
you know we are we are limited by the
situation we're in we're also limited by
the other agents you know in our
environment and and then you you can
kind of say okay well maybe it's a bit
of both so there are guard rails there
are trajectories that are takeable but
we still have some Choice over those
trajectories yeah yeah exactly um so we
were talking about this a little bit
earlier today um about semantics of
language right and like how language and
itself has a form of agency but it's
only a function of its users as well um
and so I think you can kind of draw a
parallel over there where all of these
interactions that are happening between
different
agents it is certain restrictions that
you're having but it I that is not what
truncates your sense of agency you still
have the ability to act and the want to
act the will to act right
um the things that are explaining your
actions are also limited by your own
generative model so are you sampling the
world to support your generative model
to test your
hypothesis
um so in a way I guess it is a little
bit paradoxical to say that your agency
is limited
um or restricted by all of these
different processes but it is those
processes that allow you to be an agent
in the first
place yeah I was speaking to Carl about
this earlier both the the outer loop of
as an agent I seek new information you
know to learn about my sense world uh
and also this idea of language as being
a super
organism um the reason I think that's a
delicious thought experiment is we were
teasing apart the extent to which k as a
materialist and when you think of
virtual agents which are um you know
composed of a distributed set of
underlying physical agents and their
actions are as if they're not direct
actions so um they can't act because
they're not physical but you can kind of
perceive their actions like you know
like a like a meme for example you can
think of a meme as being an agent even
though it's a virtual thing and you know
so in in in some sense there could be
even a hierarchy of virtual agents yeah
and um Carl didn't like that idea very
much but what what what's your intuition
I actually quite like that idea because
as soon as there is an outcome
to the meme existing for example the
virtual agent existing there's an
interaction that's occurring that in
itself is that object acting producing
an action and it resulting in a
consequence a observation in the shared
environment of the agents that are
interacting with one another and so
again to bring back the whole like
semantics of language and it it
developing its own identity right um I
think that's the same thing with memes
memes wouldn't exist if we didn't exist
to interpret them right um but they
exist and are passing passing some
information to us and that is the
outcome in itself so it has its meaning
its semantics develops over time so it
does exist temporally it changes
temporally as well mhm um yeah so I'd
argue that it is an
agent yeah um I I think it's a beautiful
idea yeah and um as as we were saying
earlier because I guess with with Carl I
was talking about this in terms of
material non-reductionism so chmer says
Consciousness you know it arises from
configurations of material but it's
strongly emergent so it's not directly
reducible to the material um but um this
is this is an an analogy of that which
is that we have um in the information
substrate we have this super organism
which is parasitic on all of the
physical agents and even though you I
guess car was saying because you
can't um interpret the superorganism as
being physical AG that kind of broke the
link for him but yeah I'm a little bit
surprised because as long as you can dra
as long as you can draw a mark of
blanket around it yeah it then exists as
an organism and you or as an agent and
you can then pinpoint that it doesn't
matter if it's material or not right
yeah um so we can draw a mark of blanket
around the two of us right now but it
doesn't have to be a
materialistic
um continuous actual thing that exists
right
so y yeah I'm a little bit surprised
there so another another thing that i'
I've always tried to ask Kyle about is
um I I love playing around with this
idea that the boundaries are Observer
relative yeah um so I guess like maybe
we could make the case for on the one
hand the boundaries exist universally
and on the other hand they are based on
your perspective yeah and I think the an
activist Viewpoint is very much
about you know my situated knowledge my
lived experience my perspective of
things yeah so where do you fall on that
dichotomy I think it's Observer relative
um because you can say a hallucination
in itself exists for one person right um
there is a statistical boundary over
there there is some level of an
interaction over there the hallucination
in itself is an agent it is also inter
like it's inter acting with the other
agent it um moves around space it moves
around time it has its own
Dynamics um and so that's why it is then
Observer relative which is if I can see
it and I can experience it you perhaps
don't doesn't mean that it doesn't exist
for me interesting okay so from a from a
modeling perspective then we
would I suppose this is this is
consistent with if you build a
distributed system if you implement the
ACTA pattern yeah um it's just software
engineering best practice you you would
encapsulate the actors so every actor
has its own boundaries that it draws
based on its perception and in that book
down there by Andy Clark he says that
almost everything we experience as a
hallucination yeah mostly you know
because and again it's like we said well
language conditions our generative model
actually all of our sensation um
conditions our generative model yeah and
what we're doing over time by minimizing
Sur prior is creating this very high
fidelity generative model of the world
that we live in mhm but then from this
boundary point of VI you know we were
saying earlier it's it's a miracle that
we can even communicate and understand
each other communicate with and
understand yeah because clearly there's
a lot of Divergence there because we
have different experiences and we can
overcome the brittleness God knows how
but we can experience the same things we
can at least feel we understand things
in the same way we can communicate with
each other yeah and and now we're trying
to build distributed software systems
that use active inference that overcome
this brittleness yeah how how's that how
does that work oh gosh how does that
work if I had the answer to that we
wouldn't be over here with a team of
researchers I wish I had the answer to
that um no we're still working on that
we're still developing it we're trying
to scale it up in a very manageable
practical manner that is still very very
principled I think that is
just Carl does an excellent job of just
keeping us grounded to make sure that
everything is done in a principled
manner so then we really get the
emergent properties from the
propositions of the model I'm hoping we
can form some some form of a digital
version of intelligence as captured by
our reality of intelligence that exists
all around us not only like non-human
intelligence as well right I think the
way to overcome the brittleness is to
build a sufficiently high resolution
model which is to say you start very low
down the stack so you rely on the
self-organization and emergence and so
on and clearly well not clearly I mean
let's say the same thing has happened in
the universe so the universe is a big
computer yeah and this thing has this is
the existence case of it basically so
let's say in principle we could build
this collective intelligence from from
The Roots side and and then we're we're
not we're not explicitly building an
intelligence we're growing it yeah right
so then we need to steer it and we need
to try and make it we need to try and
bend it to our
will but now you're being the controller
right but if there is a system like this
an
ecosystem it would have several emergent
properties that would exist on their own
what do you mean by steering it then
well I mean let's use society as an
example of an emerging in super
intelligent system yeah and we steer it
with governance yeah and you know it's
like hurting cats isn't it it's very
very difficult so I guess like if we did
and and we're talking about building a
distributed system MH um so almost by
Design you can't control like all you
can do is influence you can you can send
messages to all of the agents yeah yeah
exactly they will all interpret the
message with their you know with their
model yeah exactly so I can you know on
the one hand that's very um robust but
it's also quite
dangerous because what if it doesn't do
what I want it to
do yeah um but again this is just a
product of the agents that exist in this
distributed system right so I think this
is an argument that Mike Levin has made
quite a few times of just
um you don't try to grow an arm by just
working from a very bottom up level
there's a lot of top- down processes
that you can just do you can just
instruct them this is the notion that
biology uses what I call a multiscale
competency architecture which basically
means that we are not simply nested
structurally in terms of cells which
comprise tissues comprising organs the
bodies and then ultimately societies and
so on that's obviously true on a
structural level but more interesting is
the fact that each of these layers has
certain problemsolving competencies each
one solves problems in their own space
so cells are simultaneously solving
problems in physiological spaces and
metabolic spaces and gene expression
spaces and tissues and organs are
solving those problems but for example
during embryogenesis or regeneration
they're also solving problems in
anatomical space or the little cells the
proteins that whatever that's involved
um to grow an arm and it does right so
steering in a way of not trying to
manipulate things from a bottom up level
but a very top down level which is what
kind of what governance does but it
exists as a function of us as agents
living in this hierarchical level I
don't have to understand how my cells
are acting right I don't have to
instruct them in any particular way so
through self-organization you get Global
coherence and systems in biology do this
all the time you can cut worms half and
they regrow back so when you look at
let's say culture or a very
complex collective intelligence MH um
you can't really steer and when I say
steer I'm not saying talk to the
individuals I'm saying like do some kind
of you know how could applying pressures
to it to make it do the thing I want it
to do and less of the thing I don't want
it to do okay um that seems really
difficult maybe it's also just a matter
of like resilience the agent it's just
um practicing resilience it may be an
instruction or a pressure that would
break the system right and so it just
refuses to enter the system well let's
say um I mean you studi depression right
so so I want to minimize uh rates of
depression in my Society so what do I do
I I um I make some
laws i i i mandate that people only work
eight hours a day and I try and reduce
psychosocial stress and blah blah blah I
do a whole bunch of stuff and there are
so many problems here so first of all
how do you measure depression is it like
how many people are taking
anti-depressants how many people are
killing themselves yeah I mean you're
you're trying to control a population
when the problem exists in an individual
level
right well that's interesting I mean is
that your interpretation like do you do
you think of depression
individualistically very very
individualistically so there are a lot
of individual differences simply because
the processes that are engaged within it
is contextualized for each and every
individual and
so let's say uh depression could exist
because I experienced a certain event
early on in my life and I adopted a
strategy that strategy worked during
that time and now I've learned that that
strategy is helpful mhm it allows me to
overcome that traumatic event um and so
I adopt that strategy for the rest of my
life but now I have to unlearn that
right but it's
so it's so um embedded within the system
and etched into the system that
unlearning it just becomes a little bit
of a harder process but that event is
different for a lot of different people
right you're perceiving it differently
already it's influencing you in your
life very very differently strategies
that perhaps you could um adopt as you
interact with your world a little bit
differently or you learn about your
world a little bit differently or you
might have wrong information about the
world so there's so many different
things but if you're now trying to
create a very generalized perspective by
saying take a warm bath and have some
candles once in a while and that will
regulate your depression do some
self-care and things like that like it's
not really going down to the root or
tackling the cognitive process it's
suppressing the symptom a little bit and
that's it well I think I think you could
argue it both ways so I mean
traditionally on the left um people
would try and look at the um the broad
brush causal factors things like the
social the you know relative inequality
psychosocial environment blah blah blah
and you could go even more extreme to
the personalized view than you just did
yeah and you can say okay well um I want
to understand the exact uh mechanism
that is causing my depression you know
at the brain level and that would
actually be unintelligible I would argue
so you can kind of go one step up and
and it can be a very personalized
approach I can go and get CBT I can
understand the triggers I can do this I
can do and it might you know it might be
my sleep it might be you know my
neurotransmitters I you know ssris blah
blah it could be a whole Myriad of
different things but I have a very
personalized approach to it and I guess
like but the question is or or even as a
government I could still kind of do what
you said and um instill The Meta skill
so I can say rather than being
prescriptive I can say you need to get
some assistance and you need to uncover
what it is for you but so there's a
whole Spectrum here but I guess like
what we're saying is that you could
still um it's not a binary it's very
complex but you could still move the
needle and yeah and the really
interesting thing about complex systems
in my opinion is that sometimes if you
do like if you follow the gradient of
the thing you want to do you cause an
equal and opposite reaction mhm so you
you know like paradoxically you might
create more depression than you cured
yeah you could I mean more generally
speaking we just need to understand a
lot better before we um produce laws
like this but I I totally understand
what you're saying now which is just
this top down change that you can do
allows
allows the changes to occur like if you
think about all of this in a
hierarchical nested manner right when
you're instilling that topown message it
allows the lower level systems to be a
little bit more malleable and learn from
those instructions learn from the
messages that are being passed at the
high level and so what that does
is even for us then at an individual
level when we receive that message now
that I'm aware of the thing things that
perhaps I should improve or change or
are you know not wrong with me but you
get dysfunctional with me perhaps um
then I can practice some top- down
exercises to help me regulate the exact
thing that I have now become aware of
right instead so instead of it being
simply a bottomup message it's being
counteracted by a top down message at
the same time which is that the equal
reac thing Mike Levan and he is a real
inspiration to me yeah to us all so um
because he's he's got this beautiful um
I mean he is a biologist I guess the
clues in the name but this um wonderful
take on on how life emerges gradually
yeah and I guess
traditionally people have always thought
of these bright lines in evolution and
biology a bright Line Between Us and
other animals or a bright line you know
between different classes of
intelligence say and his view is very
much that it's just a Continuum
yeah what's the question Tim well um am
I supposed to say something there let's
let's talk about like Evolution what are
what are your thoughts on
Evolution do I believe in evolution I
trust I trust you believe in evoltion
yeah I do um well I think it's simply
and capsulated by emergent properties
that exist from all of these different
agents existing at so many different
levels hierarchically temporally
spatially some survive some don't it's
all about resilience
sustainability um it's a beautiful
process to watch and it's a beautiful
process to learn from um we know that
there are some
core principles that exist throughout
Evolution that drive it it's a kind of
search process which accumulates
information and unlike almost every
other search process that we've created
in computers it never converges it's
just still diverging just continuously
accumulating information and
complexity well yes so now this is where
I think practical um implementations of
agent Frameworks come unstuck because
they explicitly model goals assuming
that they were always there in the real
physical systems in my opinion they were
not it just seems like they were the
trick is that agency is an
epistemological reference frame which
can be applied to Virtual or emergent
phenomena like a culture or elements
within it it might sound like a radical
idea that abstract processes like
Evolution might have agency or some kind
of decomposition of agency remember
agency is a lens in some cases agents
are physical things which is to say some
things are agents but in my opinion not
all agents are things
so let's talk about Evolution we
anthropomorphize everything and we
assume individual humans have goals or
plans I think that evolution is a far
less understood phenomenon than we
realize we discussed this a little bit
with Professor Kenneth Stanley goals are
an anthropocentric concept right so they
make more sense at the individual human
level but even then does a typical human
have a goal to find food well kind of
it's all by chemical signals at the end
of the day finding food is an abstract
interpretation of an abstract social
category now consider the phenomenon of
carcinization The evolutionary process
that led to unrelated species converging
on a crab likee form now this is a mere
Quirk of nature arguably or could it
signal a deeper Behavioral or
mechanistic pattern carcinization is a
form of morphologically convergent
evolution which is fascinating but is it
a phenomena or is it a behavior well
personally I don't care let's say it's a
phenomenon but what I'm arguing is that
humans don't explicitly plan either it
just appears as if we do any AIS which
explicitly plan like Alpha go are not
doing it in the way that it actually
happens in physical reality you could
argue that it was planning which
explains cariz but the reality is much
more mundane we Ed the lens of planning
to explain many things in reality there
are no plans now you can model pretty
much anything with an agent for example
the actor pattern of computation can
model any computation you know my main
argument for precluding the existence of
AGI is that intelligence is a physical
process or a process which supervenes on
a physical process for example culture
or an organization I think it would be
possible to achieve AGI as it exists
with a very high resolution simulation
of a physical process uh which in my
opinion would be beyond anything that we
could build in the future and like wolf
says there's no shortcuts right it talks
about computational irreducibility so
it's not that I'm anti- functionalist I
just don't think this would be possible
in practice if you look at the the
philogenetic tree yeah and you look at
the independent evolution of
intelligences in different directions in
that
philogyny
um because I guess now we're zooming out
over time well simply that they've
become more and more complex with time
right and intelligence has existed from
the get-go because I I believe that
there are limits to intelligence okay so
um even though we've seen this monotonic
complexification and accumulation of
information yeah um do you think we will
see agents in the future that are
significantly more intelligent than
humans and and if we did what would that
mean what does it mean more intelligent
though that's a good question what do
you think it means I think right now
when we're talking about it in this
context we are comparing to human
intelligence and simply using that as a
baseline so intelligence here would be
can um Can a certain agent just behave
in the world more efficiently and more
adaptively intelligence exists
contextually depending on the
organism and its abilities so it's you
can't say whether something is more
intelligent or less intelligent it just
is intelligent yeah pay Wang has this
definition which is the adaptation
efficiency given limited resources and
that's very interesting um I think from
an embodied point of view you can kind
of think about it in terms of
efficiently exploiting your physical
environment um there are folks who lean
towards a pure form of intelligence you
know which is talking about being able
to um efficiently create skill programs
from limited prior and experience okay
or being able to you know just from a
decision theoretical point of view being
able to take the best trajectory of
actions given limited information yeah
um so yeah I've noticed a real divide in
the community between people who believe
in a pure intelligence versus something
which is
physically um situated like where do you
fall on that spectr so what does it mean
by it to be physically
situated so um I yes if you're an agent
in an environment um you can only act by
doing things in that environment yeah so
in that sense intelligence can only be
viewed through the lens of things that
you can physically do whereas another
view is I don't know you can take
platonic forms for example like being
able to do algebra and knowing what a
circle is and you could argue that these
things are so abstract and Universal
that they don't bear any resemblance
whatsoever to our physical world now
agents are a lens that can be applied to
absolutely anything this was from an
unreleased show with Kristen uh which we
will eventually release on uh you know
with some of the other material that
we've got on intelligence um I say that
intelligence is discretionarily
constrained adaptation under
insufficient knowledge and resources so
there we bring in um the ability to uh
to create goals to create sub goals to
compare goals to evaluate goals and and
contemplate
plans as well so this adaptation it's
not the same adaptation um as we find in
biology it it is a different kind of
adaptation it's discretionarily
constrained adaptation so it is informed
uh choice-driven
adaptation in light of potentially uh
constrained or or limited time energy uh
and
knowledge I believe that uh pang's
definition is by far the best definition
uh that has come forth so far in the
field of AI and I actually think that it
it also works for natural intelligence
in fact I think it's a general
definition of intelligence uh that works
uh across the board and I I am
absolutely convinced that this will be
the prevailing definition uh for
intelligence um in in the years and
decades to come but notice how Christen
is smuggling in goals again every body
loves the goals don't they I find this
extraordinarily bizarre given an AI
researchers should be better aware of
their own anthropocentric biases he
himself said that pay Wang's model is a
biological one and well isn't that what
we want don't we want the high
resolution biological model so in my
opinion nothing physical has abstract
goals right abstract goals are just our
lens are software any software we
program with explicit goals will never
be an AGI because there are no shortcuts
to AGI that's my opinion now even though
human agents appear to plan and
therefore have goals because of the
relative entropy of their behavior with
respect to their local environment both
in terms of time and space the planning
is in fact mostly diffused outside of
the brain in the environment when we
seek information in our environment
through this autodidactic exchange which
friston speaks of we build an
incremental COG nitive map over time the
topology of which might even resemble a
plan because time is implicitly built
into the map we then greedily sample
this map to perform actions to an
observer it would appear as if we were
planning when in fact the planning is
unrolled in time and space over the
physical dynamics of the environment
that we are in and that information is
acquired into our cognitive map through
this incremental information exchange
now this is a purely externalist account
you know just for rhetorical effect I
can accept maybe that humans in fact do
some combination of planning as well as
this as if planning that I'm talking
about but in practice it's a pointless
distinction in my opinion now the
fascinating thing is that all of this
intelligent computation is just an
unrolled process of recursive
information exchange just like how a
class 4 2D cellular autometer can
represent any computation even though
the unit of computation is simply moving
information around a grid now we could
go Phil opical on whether goals
ontologically exist the philosopher
Philip gof argues for an account of pan
agential ISM in his new book why the
purpose of the universe which is to say
that perhaps entalis is woven into the
fabric of the universe itself and all
material has degrees of it from a
nativist and psychology perspective I
believe that they exist in us they shape
how we think about things for example
Daniel dennett's intentional stance
comes in I think they are largely
epistemological not ontological which is
to say they exist as knowledge they
shape how we think but for all intents
and purposes they don't actually exist
in reality with the exception of
physical things which are themselves
agents now does a script writer for a
film have a goal does the director have
a goal what is the director's goal what
is the editor's goal what emerges in the
end like is it the same thing as what
the script writer imagined hell no the
film emerges from the material
and the material emerges from the
physical processes that were recurring
when they were filmed you know any
planning that the agents may appear to
have done was actually embedded and
diffused in the wider system now in my
opinion real physical agents as we know
them they don't plan right certainly not
as we think they do is is is the concept
of an agent like a fundamental thing is
it something we've constructed or is it
like a fundamental thing in the
universe I think it's a way for us to
understand the Universe I don't think we
can ever make the argument of whether or
not it truly foundationally exists or
not for us we can believe that it does
and that's why it helps us understand
the world a little bit better um but
whether or not it really exists I mean
we are all ultimately hallucinating this
right yeah but then like speaking as a
psychologist that's the interesting
thing which is that everything we know
and can conceive of mhm is just
traversing our our prize right our our
kind of psychological prize which means
everything we can experience or conceive
of is
anthropomorphic yeah so in some sense
there's this Veil um or you know like
wool that kind of stops us from knowing
anything about physical reality yes
exactly
yeah and so
um yeah I guess I guess in in a way it's
it's kind of depressing because we can
only ever know ourselves
oh yeah absolutely I mean this um
touches a long
umwelt do you know term yes that's the
word um I think that's what you're kind
of touching along um which
is you only ever understand the world
through your perception and it's limited
by your
senses and that's it you only know what
you know you don't know what you don't
know what Ed young does um in one of his
books called immense World which I've
thoroughly enjoyed reading um would
highly recommend it to you as well um it
takes a dive into
objectively more even scientifically
explaining to us in our language that we
would understand it what the systems the
sensory systems are like of other
organisms other animals right so they
have a different umwelt they can see
different colors they C their visual
system um in terms of how many things
they can focus on um to what like what
degrees the visual field like the um
area of the visual field differs along
different
organisms and so we can never really
imagine what they would see the world as
how they would be perceiving the world
right you really don't know what you
don't know and you can't imagine it I
you can't imagine a new color I I know
and then I spoke with K about this
earlier this is very similar to nagle's
bat you know which is like what what is
it like to be a bat and a bat yeah so um
Thomas Nagel um wrote this essay what's
it like to be a bat and he basically
said that you know they they use echol
location to get around yeah and but
that's a description we'll never know
what echolocation actually looks feels
like no no it's it's inconceivable but
then you could say well that's that's
phenomenology right so we can we can
talk a lot about experience or you can
just be really no nonsense and just talk
about generative models and evidence and
so on and so then you then you can talk
about you know I guess it's more from a
knowledge point of view or from a
generative model point of view what it's
like to be a bad yeah but so many
philosophers say that it's really
important to understand the experience
of being a bat exactly you know because
there is no understanding without the
requisite experience MH I mean where do
you fool on that yeah I agree with that
um you it depends on why you're
conducting this level of analysis right
so if you are simply trying to
understand the Dynamics of it in a
language that you can understand then
yeah you can use generative models to
try and understand what a bat would
experience um or how it would interact
or how any other a agent in the world
would interact you you're using a
language to describe it that you would
understand but if you're really trying
to phen
phenomenologically understand what any
other organism would feel like I in all
fairness like I don't know what it is
like to be you I can use a generative
model to describe and kind of get an
idea of it but I'll never really know
mhm and that's kind of the beauty of it
you have to trust that like it's
untouchable
right yeah it is and I mean this is
related to um John Soul's Chinese room
argument yeah um so yeah that in terms
of understanding there'll always be um a
level of resolution which is you know
beyond reach for a computer machines
couldn't understand our subjective
experience assuming we have them yeah um
Carl says that it's for all intents and
purposes we don't have it we just think
we do but but yeah but the question we
have a subjective experience Carl said
earlier that he doesn't really believe
he thinks it's kind of like an illusion
you know our conscious experience yeah
yeah but an interesting question is do
you think a machine could have a
subjective experience as well as we
could have one I agree with him that it
is an illusion and so I think we could
be convinced that it does and so
ultimately if we treat it like it does
then in our experience it does have a
subjective um experience so if for me
for whatever reason I believe that chair
has an entity and that it's sacred and I
it's it's all about the semantics of it
right things mean thing like they have
meaning to humans for some reason
MH such a complex thing to understand
and get into and try and
like understand it as well via active
inference and llms and everything that's
going on
but I can truly believe that it has an
entity
and that's it it only has to exist in my
experience for that to be a reality to
me yeah and I think Emanuel K spoke
about this kind of veil of perception
but um there are so many uncanny valys
we've seen uncanny valys with language
models recently where they're they're so
indistinguishably lifelike that they may
as well be real and it's the same thing
what you were just saying which is that
you know our generative models of the
world are so high resolution yeah as to
the point that we could basically be
hallucina I mean we think we are
hallucinating something which actually
exists and that seems to be a difference
which is to say well if it is just a
precise simulacrum of reality then it
kind of doesn't matter but if it's
different from reality um because of the
uncanny valley like you could still say
in some sense it exists to you yes but
we don't want to get into any kind of um
kooky philosophy about idealism or you
know like this idea that it it's almost
like it doesn't matter what exists in
the physical world the only thing that
exists are what exists in my mental
world yeah because then we wouldn't be
able to survive as a society right if
everyone
to be more delusional about the world
let's say
um it it results in dysfunction within
the society and I think us communicating
about our shared experiences allows us
to calibrate whether or not this thing
actually exists cuz if you and I can
both see a ghost in the
room to it's a reality it's grounded
yeah and I I guess this this is the
fascinating thing that um you know like
we were saying earlier that it's a
miracle that there is any coherence and
synchronization at all and yeah so there
is the grounding of existing in the sh
in the same physical space yeah so even
though ironically you might you might
say everything is a hallucination yeah
um because
we it coalesces we synchronize um we
have this inductive resonance if you
like and it just BEC toity and the same
happens with our language it does yeah
in a very weird distributed way that's
the thing because you're sitting on that
chair now and you have the same
conception of a chair as lots of other
people because they've sat on similar
chairs maybe that chair maybe another
chair and it's all just kind of coales
at some abstract
level yeah absolutely I mean um have you
watched Black Mirror yes the latest
season no maybe which one are you
thinking oh wait no I'm have you watched
the one with Miley Cyrus in it no oh
okay tell us about it there's this
um this robot that is based off of Miley
Cyrus as a celebrity icon I have seen
that right and the person who owns the
toy really assigns a lot of meaning to
it it has a subjective experience
because she doesn't want to hurt the
robot anymore right that exists as a
reality for her she very well knows
knows that this is a robot um and then
there's also a similar situation with
meta I think they I think it was last
week that I came across this on
Instagram where they released some
virtual agent called Billy which is deep
faked Kendall J K Kendall Jenner I don't
know what her name is oh okay yeah yeah
they they've released about 20 Bots like
there's a Snoop Dog one and oh yeah yeah
yeah exactly but I think which is a bit
weird by the way it is it is incredibly
weird to me because she said that she
was Billy because she said she was Billy
which was not her name um only then do
you know that it's not actually her and
so I've been given information now that
this is a simulation and so now it's my
choice according to my generative model
whether or not I want to believe that it
has a subjective experience if I don't
want it to then it won't when these
people make these gestures and say these
things in real life there is a
concomittant subject of experience there
is and and then you know what what's the
that's the thing like there are so many
weird you know uncanny valleys that
we're starting to experience now they're
teaching us about intelligence and
agency and and conscious experience yeah
and the remarkable thing I don't know
whether you saw that there was Alex
fredman with Mark Zuckerberg and they
were avatars so they were both wearing
virtual reality headsets ah okay and
they weren't in the same physical room
okay they believed that they were
because in virtual reality there's a
very high resolution generative Avatar
and they they could basically almost
touch each other and it was that uncanny
valley they may as well have been in the
same room yeah it was indistinguishable
exactly and Lex was saying oh I just I
feel a bit weird I feel like we're
uncomfortably close M and all of these
Sensations and and you kind of know that
you're ring you're wrong to feel those
Sensations but youve kind of bridged
that uncanny valley you just have you
have like that really strong prior that
this is not real because I know that
Mark Zuckerberg is at the other side of
the world or wherever he was right yeah
but our experiences are convincing us
otherwise and it's so real it's so as
you say high resolution MH exactly and
and this is why I mentioned luchano flid
earlier who he was at Oxford and yeah
his his core thesis basically is that
we're moving
from the ontology of the physical world
to the information world yeah and you
know I guess 20 years ago everything was
in the physical world you know even like
when you spoke to your Postman you went
down the bank and everything like that
and it's happening so slowly and
perniciously so now you do all your
Banking online you do your shopping
online yeah um your relationships are
online and at some point everything will
be online maybe there'll be a
renaissance where people will go no no I
want to live more in the in the physical
world but it's almost like I think it's
already kind of happening well yeah well
well there's a blurring and and a lot of
it is to do with this phenomenology
thing you know which is that we always
intuitively thought that there was a
difference there was yeah yeah exactly
that is a very good point I'm learning
so much from
you yeah yeah uh definitely I agree with
this
and I think just by studying this a lot
more um
and kind of reproducing it via AI it
could either benefit the world or cause
a lot of chaos um and we just have to be
a little bit careful as to which one it
does
because I think we do have enough
knowledge and power to be able to guide
it in a much more ethical manner that
all of us can safely use all of these
things right mhm um it was because
meta's um virtual agent first gave me
the
information that there was a discrepancy
between the name that was used in the
agent that was projected to me
visually and that's how I knew that it
it was a deep fake if that information
was not provided to me that would have
been my reality in the wild people have
access to this technology and they're
cloning voices they're doing all of this
stuff and um I spoke with Daniel dennit
about this he's got this beautiful
article called counterfeit people
and you know he basically says we're
already at the stage now where you don't
know like it's indistinguishable it's
irreversible basically so you know did
did did a human do this did a language
model do this I don't know yeah and it's
already breaking down trust like when I
when I read LinkedIn now I mean
linkedin's already pretty bad to start
with it's just language models language
models so like how do you think this is
going to change like everything on on
the internet it has been an absolute
honor thank you so much thank you thank
you so much I genuinely really enjoyed
this conversation so thank you amazing
cool